il se dit engagé dans les
transformations décisive de ses clients
son nom m'accuser compagnies sont
métiers le conseil en stratégie
depuis cet hiver ce cabinet américain
qui agit dans l'ombre s'est retrouvé
sous les projecteurs
et pour cause le 4 janvier le site
politico révèle que mckinley a notamment
conseillé la france dans sa stratégie
vaccinale contre le coc vite 19
le gouvernement français a également
pris la décision d'engager mckeen's est
pour le conseiller sur la logistique de
la campagne de vaccination
le cabinet de conseil à travailler avec
le gouvernement sur cette question
depuis au moins début décembre selon des
documents internes
ces conseils portait sur la définition
du cadre logistique le développement
d'un benchmark logistique par rapport à
d'autres pays et l'aide à la
coordination opérationnelle du groupe de
travail dédié a déclaré un responsable
du ministère de la santé
le 12 janvier dernier le ministre de la
santé a été interrogé par la commission
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée
nationale sur les raisons qui ont poussé
le gouvernement à faire appel à mckeen's
et olivier ferrand explique qu'il est
classique et cohérent de s'appuyer sur
l'expertisé du secteur privé selon les
informations du magazine le point le
cabinet n'interviendrait aucunement sur
les choix de nature politique et
sanitaire
une prestation de conseil qui seraient
donc facturé 2 millions d'euros par mois
selon les informations de l'hebdomadaire
la rencontre entre mckeen's et emmanuel
macron ne date en réalité pas d'hier
leurs liens remontent à 2007 selon une
enquête du quotidien le monde
le président français était alors
rapporteur général adjoint de la
commission attali pour la libération de
la croissance commission pour laquelle
le cabinet mckinsey avait
mise à disposition des consultants
gratuitement mais tout s'accélère en
2016 alors qu emmanuel macron vise
l'elysée
emmanuel macron n'a pas encore annoncé
sa candidature mais à l'été 2016 des
groupes de travail sont déjà constitués
pour élaborer son programme
on y croise thomas cazenave mais aussi
une dizaine de salariés de mckinsey il
planche sur l'économie comme sur les
dossiers régaliens les membres du
cabinet ont ils proposé leurs services
bénévolement ou sur leur temps libre
mckinsey n'a pas répondu au monde à ce
propos et le journal précise qu'aucune
trace de cette collaboration n'a été
trouvée dans les factures de la campagne
déposé à la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne et des financements
politiques
une fois emmanuel macron éludé ancien de
mckinsey le suivent
l'un devient directeur adjoint du
cabinet de mounir mahjoubi secrétaire
d'état au numérique
un autre chef du pôle projets arm enfin
eric labbé le dirigeant de mckinsey qui
siégeait à la commission attali change
aussi de métier en août 2010 8
il est nommé par emmanuel macron
président de polytechnique en réalité
maclean's et n'a pas attendu emmanuel
macron pour tisser sa toile dans les
plus hautes sphères des états déjà sous
la présidence de nicolas sarkozy la
firme avait conseillé le ministère de
l'identité nationale sur une
optimisation du processus de
naturalisation
hors de l'hexagone mckeen's et aurait
notamment travaillé avec le gouvernement
merkel sur la gestion de l'accueil des
migrants